alors comme chaque mercredi maintenant
c'est l'heure de l'édito que Régine et
donc aujourd'hui vous allez nous parler
du conseil municipal des enfants qui se
passe à Guyancourt tout à fait Mathilde
est justement j'aimerais revenir sur ce
qu'est le CME donc le conseil municipal
des enfants donc c'est une instance qui
est destinée aux enfants et le but est
d'améliorer la vie de la municipalité à
travers des projets et à Guyancourt un
maire et 35 conseillers sont élus pour
deux ans et sont généralement des élèves
de CE2 CM1 et CM2 et de sixième
également alors Walid après avoir été
conseillé pendant deux ans tu as été élu
maire ce 15 juin tu as 11 ans qu'est-ce
que ça te fait aujourd'hui d'être mère
est-ce que tu es content tu es
enthousiaste oui je suis assez contente
c'est une chance
d'être mère et pourquoi est-ce que tu as
décidé de te présenter
j'ai dessiné me présenter pour
réaliser les projets de chaque élu et
faire en sorte que
la voix de chaque élu passe
partout tu as déjà des idées en tête des
des actions oui
j'aimerais installer un club de lecture
à Guyancourt
parce que j'aime bien la lecture et je
trouve que
comme on en a pas à Guyancourt
je trouve que c'est important
l'éducation donc la lecture et tout ça
mais je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
toi
et justement les prochaines enfin les
dernières années il y avait souvent une
thématique donc l'année dernière par
exemple enfin sur les deux dernières
années le mandat portait sur la
solidarité je vous propose justement de
regarder un petit extrait
[Musique]
donc voilà on a bien vu sur la vidéo
cette petite fille qui a finalement son
goûter grâce à la solidarité alors
Richard Mézières et Walid Bastet est-ce
que vous avez une idée aujourd'hui de
sur quelle thématique va apporter le
mandat alors aujourd'hui le mandat du
CME du 7e CME va porter il faut que les
déjà que les élus travaillent entre eux
ils vont avoir des commissions à la
rentrée pour travailler en fonction des
différentes professions de fois pour
proposer des thèmes ce qu'on a pu déjà
voir et peut-être que vous voyez de Me
confirmerait on a eu beaucoup de choses
autour du harcèlement scolaire je pense
que tous nos jeunes élus sont très
sensibles et ont envie de s'impliquer
travailler pour faire être attentif aux
autres et être vigilant sur le
harcèlement scolaire je sais pas où
habite
sensibiliser un peu plus là dessus
d'habitude notre CME fait des vidéos la
vidéo qu'on vient de voir c'est eux qui
l'ont travaillé ceux qui l'ont écrit
d'ailleurs on a vu walidocious
et donc ils vont proposer peut-être on
fait des fois des ateliers bandes
dessinées on fait des défunts on fait
des dessins pardon on peut faire une
vidéo voir du théâtre voir des
animations donc ça sera aux élus du CME
de choisir sur quel mode ils vont
choisir quel mode ils vont mettre en
place pour faire ces animations autour
et on parle du harcèlement mais ils sont
aussi très sensibles à l'environnement
on parle beaucoup de ramasser continuer
à faire des ateliers autour du recyclage
du ramassage des déchets les collectes
mais c'est leur travail donc à eux de
travailler ils vont prendre des vacances
juin maintenant c'est deux mois de
vacances mais au retour des vacances un
premier similaire intégration et puis
après tous les mercredis en septembre ça
reprend alors comment est-ce qu'on fait
pour se présenter comment ça se passe
tu as fait une campagne
bah en fait
il faut d'abord
il faut déposer sa candidature puis
faire sa profession de foi
ensuite les
les enfants de
ma commune vont voter pour les 35 élus
sont tous les enfants des écoles
primaires qui votent exactement
et donc tous les enfants ont affiché des
leurs professions de foi et puis après
chacun peut lire les professions de voir
alors après quand les enfants sont de
loisirs ou quand c'est les enfants sont
dans les écoles c'est en partenariat
avec les enseignants les enseignants
organisent un petit peu des débats pour
que les enfants de l'école qui se
présentent puissent partager un peu leur
programme
et puis après sur la journée de vote et
ben chacun des enfants choisissent ou
candidats et votre
ça fait plus de 30 ans qu'il y a un
conseil municipal des enfants à
Guyancourt c'est d'ailleurs l'une des
premières villes en France à avoir
initié cet instant finalement vous avez
dû recul qu'est-ce que ça apporte à la
ville d'avoir un conseil municipal des
enfants ça apporte déjà de faire une
remontée de la voix des enfants
aujourd'hui il y a des certaines
sensibilités que nous en tant qu'adulte
on a peut-être pas où on n'est pas assez
vigilant mais en tous les cas d'avoir ce
conseil municipal des enfants ça nous
rappelle des voix déjà souvent à l'ordre
sur des choses qu'on a tendance un peu
oublier ça permet aussi de d'avoir un
avis sur une ville à hauteur d'enfants
nous on voit pas forcément les choses
comme les enfants parce que pour des
raisons de taille et puis pour des
raisons d'ouverture et donc ça nous
apporte ce point de vue là
alors comment est-ce que vous les
accompagnez au quotidien dans leur
démarche début comment ça se passe
municipal de un service qui est écrit
autour du conseil municipal des enfants
avec deux animateurs et une responsable
de services donc qui font toutes ces
tout ce travail le mercredi après-midi
tous les mercredis après-midi au cours
de l'année vacances il faut quand même
qu'il garde du temps pour se reposer
c'est pour ça que c'est aussi un vrai
investissement pour les enfants parce
que c'est tous les mercredis de
l'après-midi de l'année
sur lequel il se réunissent en groupe
entier et en sous-groupe pour travailler
sur des ateliers donc ça c'est les
services de la ville qui les accompagne
et puis on va aussi voir des des
institutions je crois qu'à la fin de
l'année il y aura une visite à
l'Assemblée nationale qui sera organisée
pour aller découvrir la nationale et
puis quand ils ont des thèmes
particuliers on peut être amenés à les
voir comment ça se passe dans une
déchetterie je crois que la dernière
fois vous avez visité à son loterie
et tout ça c'est des projets qui
t'intéressent découvrir l'Assemblée
nationale
est-ce que plus tard tu aimerais être
mère ou être active dans dans la
politique
voire président ah oui mais en mission
donc le souhaite en tout cas Walid basta
merci beaucoup merci Charles Mézières et
Walid basta d'avoir accepté notre
invitation en plateau